the activity here on the outskirts of
hanover
certainly has the feel of a significant
development
federal police and prosecutors who are
both at the scene
have confirmed this is linked to their
inquiry
into the disappearance of madeleine
mccann an excavator has been clearing
land near a main road
and next to an allotment where the prime
suspect in the mccann investigation
lived for a time forty-three-year-old
christian bee
rented a trailer near the allotment and
spent time living here and in portugal
authorities haven't said what exactly
they're looking for here
they always with sniffing dogs they are
there with big digging machines there
there was a lot of
a lot of police they are there for two
days searching the complete ground
and and putting stuff away but also
putting stuff in plastic bags i think
for further investigations
so it looks like they got something
there but
i mean i don't know exactly what in the
13 years since madeleine mccann's
disappearance
from an apartment complex in prior to
lose
there have been numerous lines of
inquiry
but no key evidence that pointed to a
prime suspect
german investigators believe christian
bee
is that man he'd lived in prior duluz on
a number of occasions
mobile phone cell site evidence revealed
his phone
had taken a call in prior to lose an
hour before
madeleine mccann disappeared on the 3rd
of may
2007. 13 years have passed since the
disappearance of
madeleine mccann and every day of that
the witnesses get more difficult to find
the forensic evidence
more difficult to find and tracking down
the movements of any suspect more
difficult
time makes it very difficult and this is
a big ask after that period of time
christian b is currently in jail
appealing a conviction
for the rape of a 72 year old woman in
prior duluz in 2005.
he has several other convictions for sex
and drug offences
german authorities say they have
evidence which has convinced them
madeleine mccann is no longer alive
but so far it's understood their prime
suspect
is refusing to cooperate with
investigators
mark white sky news